It's the ultimate victory for self-made politician, Yoshihide Suga,...
...who in a career spanning decades...
....has finally risen to the highest political office in the land.
In contrast to many of Japan's previous prime ministers,...
...his predecessor Shinzo Abe included,...
...Suga does not come from one of Japan's elite political dynasties.
He's the son of a strawberry farmer.
His elevation means a change in style but not in substance.
As a faithful right-hand man to Abe,...
...he is expected to follow the same conservative economic policies...
...while applying his acknowledged problem solving skills...
...to the continuing COVID-19 crisis and the ill-fated Tokyo Olympics...
...that the pandemic has delayed and now threatens to wreck.
A well-known figure on the domestic political stage,...
...it was Suga as powerful chief cabinet secretary...
...who heralded last year's succession of emperors,...
...unveiling the name of the new imperial era.